alright we're on problem number nine at
least for the first next the the next
few I don't think I have to copy and
paste these problems I can just write it
so they it looks like a little bit of
algebraic long division problem nine
they want us to divide 2x plus 7 into
it's pretty long so I'll give some space
to X to the fourth plus 21 X to the
third plus 35 x squared minus 37 X plus
46 this might look daunting but once you
start it's not so bad
so like any long division you kind of
look at the biggest place in the plate
the largest degreed place at least in
this polynomial is a 2x place and that's
what we work with so we say how many
times does 2x go into 2x to the fourth
let's see the 2 goes into 2 one time and
X goes into the X to the fourth X to the
third time's right what's X to the
fourth divided by X is X to the third so
we say it goes into it X to the third
times and if we were right when we
multiply we should get 2x to the fourth
so X to the third times 2x is 2x to the
fourth and then X third times seven is
plus 7x to the third right if this was
like a you know some other if this was
well we'll worry about it when we get to
it but you would have you would want to
put it under the appropriate place in
this number but just happen to be that X
to the third was the next one now you
subtract just like you do with regular
long division these cancel out 21 minus
seven is 14 X to the third and then you
could bring down all of this but what
can worry about that in a second so how
many times does 2x go into 14 X to the
third well 2 goes into 14 seven times
plus 7 and X goes into X to the third x
squared times and four right when we
multiply it should work out so 7x
squared times 2x is equal to 14 X to the
third like we thought it should 7x
squared times 7 is what that's plus 49
49 X square
and now we subtract 14x to the 3rd minus
14x to the 3rd that's 0 now we have 35
we could bring this down just if it
makes it easier 35 x squared 35 x
squared - 49 x squared let's see so it's
minus 14 right 49 minus 35 is ready so
it's minus 14x squared and then 2 X goes
into minus 14x squared so 2 goes into
minus 14 minus 7 x and then X goes into
x squared x times when you multiply this
- 7 x times 2 X so you get minus 7 times
2 is minus 14x times X is x squared of
course you have to multiply it times
both terms right we're multiplying times
this hold expression minus 7x times 7 is
minus 49 X - 49 X now we're ready to
subtract again and I'm running out of
space
these cancel out we could bring this -
37 X down so minus 37 X and we're
subtracting this right we could almost
say we could almost add the negative
right let's make the negative so it's
this is minus 37 X minus - 49 X the same
thing as minus 37 X plus 49 X I added I
made both of those positive just to
simplify it in my brain whoops I didn't
want to go down that much okay so this
is equal to these cancel out and then
this is equal to 12 X + 2 X plus 7 goes
into 12x well now let's see 2 goes into
12 6 times X goes into X one time so
then this is equal to + 6 6 times 2x + 7
6 times 2x I know you can't see it as 12
X and then 6 times the 7 6 times 7 is 42
42 we have a 46 up there I should have
written smaller so you get us 46 and now
we're ready to subtract again 12x minus
12x is the
46 - 42 is 4 so we have a remainder of 4
so let's see our answer is all of this
with a remainder of 4 so all of that
plus the remainder over what we're doing
using 2 divided into 2x plus 7 so it's
our answer let's see what choice it is
it's X to the 3rd plus 7x squared minus
7x plus 6 plus 4 over 2x plus 7 we just
took our remainder and say okay whatever
this is that's also there so that is
choice it's the X to the 3rd plus 7x
squared minus 7x minus 7x plus 6 plus 4
over 2x plus 7 it's not let's see yeah I
can actually show you what I'm lady so
it's actually choice D is our answer I
was just reading I was just reading
choice a I should have shown you that on
the so choice D is our answer next
question problem number 10 no one took
up more space than I expected problem
number 10 which polynomial represents so
they want us to multiply this is how
they write it 3x squared plus X minus 4
times 2x minus 5
I find this and just you know multiply
these the way I would multiply any
number so I would multiplied rewrite it
as 3x squared plus X minus 4 times and I
put the same degree under the same
degree times 2x minus 5 and now let's
take the zeroth degree place I guess you
could view it that way minus 5 times
minus 4 is plus 20 minus 5 times X is
minus 5 X minus 5 times 3x squared is
minus 15 x squared minus 15 x squared 2x
times minus 4 is minus 8x I'll put it in
this place because that's our X's space
minus 8x 2x times X is 2x squared 2x
squared and then I should have had all
of this actually I think
can't do that let me see if I can move
all of this to the right the magic of
computers I can't move it all to the
right although after I should color that
back in let's see if I could color that
look at that all right back in business
all right so I did two x times minus 4
is minus 8x 2x times X is 2x squared 2x
times 3x squared is 6x to the third 6x
to the third this is a plus now we just
add up everything and up everything so
we get 6x to the third minus 15 plus 2
minus 13x squared minus 13x plus 20 so
6x to the third minus 13x squared I'm
just checking all the choices minus 13x
plus 20 that's choice B problem 11
problem 11 let's see they wrote they
wrote minus 2 this is problem 11 just so
you know what we're doing minus 2x
squared plus 6x plus 1 minus 2 times 4x
squared minus 3x plus 1 is equal to well
now we just have to simplify this let me
rewrite this part this is minus 2x
squared plus 6x plus 1 and I have to
distribute this the I've you know let's
just rib you 2 minus 2 so minus 2 times
4x squared is minus 8x squared that's
that minus 2 times minus 3 X that's + 6
X minus 2 times 1 is minus 2 and now
let's see we can add the like terms up
let's see what this is equal to let's do
the x squared term so first I'll do the
minus 2x squared and minus 8x squared so
that is minus 2 minus 8 that's minus 10x
squared let me do another color freezer
home
and then I have the X terms I have X 6x
and then have another 6x you add them
together you get 12x plus 12x and then
you have your ones terms your X to the
zeroth power you could view it you have
plus 1 and minus 2 so that's minus 1 and
then that is choice let's see let me
scroll down that is choice D minus 10 x
squared plus 12x minus 1 choice D
problem number 12 problem 12 we're on a
roll
problem 12 which expression is
equivalent to so now they're multiplying
they write 6 y squared minus 2 times 6 y
plus 2 I always find it easier to multi
in your head and you can you should
practice doing it in your head but if
you never want to make a mistake you
just write it like this 6 Y squared and
I have nothing in the X's spot and I say
minus 2 and then this one is 6y I write
that in the y spot this is y squared
this is y this is y to the 0 which is
just 1 plus 2 and now I multiply them 2
times minus 2 is minus 4 2 times 6 y
squared is 12 y squared right so I'll
write that in that spot 12 y squared now
6 Y times minus 2 is minus 12 y so
that'll go here minus 12 y and then 6y x
6 y squared is 36 Y to the third 36 fly
to the third so we have our answer it is
you just add them up 36 Y to the 3rd +
12 y squared minus 12 y minus 4 and that
is choice D and you could do this in
your head and that's a good thing to
practice but I just wanted to make sure
it was clean when I did it and let's see
should I continue with the next video or
should I stop there because I'm at 11
minutes I'll stop there and I'll see you
in the next video